what else you got chin all right last
one joe pimante you guys might recognize
this guy
or know of him gang gang buzz buzz
drip drip it was just the episode
yo i got a debate club for you this is
joey i'm your candle maker guy out here
in colorado holding her down man
and that is my question when it comes
time to make the vibes you do uh do you
like candles or
do you burn a little incense what do you
like man
keep up the good work i would like
incense better if it
if they had incense that smelled like
certain restaurants like i would love
to throw on a [ __ ] mcdonald's you
know you're on a pf chain
oh that smells right oh dude smell bf
chains them titties are
throw on a stinky uber driver's car
throwing a stick
throw on a nice young thai restaurant
incense you know what i'm saying
what if we came up with our own incense
that'd be cool that's not a bad idea oh
you really don't dude but
a little cte incense you know what i'm
saying forget where you're at
call the cosby forget what you're at and
then also at the end it sounds like bill
cosby a little
yeah but dude that would be great it
would be a good
little own king of sting incense
certain situations yeah why don't that
smells like a pawn shop
just old watches and [ __ ] medallions
yeah old watches and people getting
[ __ ] over for their family heirlooms
yeah why don't we yeah you could do like
a um a pirate ship
smells old but a little bit of salt a
little bit of seasoning on there you
know what i'm saying
dude that's a great idea it's not a bad
idea it's not a bad idea at all i wonder
how we find that and do that
and i still want to get that semen lava
lamp where you're in college everybody
can jerk off into that thing
i know you make one giant lava lamp
with a whole frat bust in the same
bottle yeah come see our bust
uh yeah our bus bulb come see it bust
bulbs
how is that not a thing call your
[ __ ] brother dude
if he quit doing bicep curls and [ __ ]
do some [ __ ] and actually make some
money
instead of just church stealing [ __ ] off
his brother like dane cook's brother
you know jay shaw is the next [ __ ]
larry cook is that his brother's name
larry i can't trust a larry come on dane
his name's larry of course he stole all
your [ __ ] you're interested in him jay
shaw bro yeah dude larry
who's flying around the country doing
curls on your dime
okay uh so candles yeah no
no incense bro i want that johnny depp
[ __ ] incense i want to burn that
incense smells like
[ __ ] bad movies i want to
burn that nick nolte incense it smells
like dinosaur bones
and [ __ ] sh and uh and like your kid
hates you
yeah i wanna burn that [ __ ] i wanna burn
that [ __ ]
why does every extremely famous
celebrity have a son that is a complete
fuck-up because his dad's so [ __ ]
famous
i need that isn't that crazy though
everything is just it's such a
teeter-totter man everything has that
other side
you don't get too famous otherwise your
kid gets really weird like look at will
smith's kid
yeah look at will smith transgender
sonny bunny maybe we don't know
yeah rapper writer i love how every
month he's a different thing that is
putting out
[ __ ] smoothie city it's like okay
pick a lane bro
yeah it doesn't end though it's nick
nolte's child tom hanks's child
you know um chaz bono well this is
that level the other side of it that's
the thing everything's even in the world
man it's like
everything's but here's the problem
though all the all the being a parent
all the people you're talking about they
were never around for the kids the kids
are there to figure out with the nanny
and the kids growing up weird yeah the
only time the dad brings you around is
that [ __ ] red carpet
this is life i'm in this weird fish bowl
yeah i love you so much i'll take you to
this thing with me now yeah i love you
so much let me fly you to
dubai for the premiere of polar express
yeah for the premiere of
pirates of the caribbean 19 where your
dad puts [ __ ] mascara on in a bandana
i know no and 17 [ __ ] wristbands can
you imagine that's weird dude you're a
girl [ __ ] weird
it's the weirdest kids out here man oh
at this [ __ ] place bro
uh what else were we talking about oh
yeah but hold on shout out to my boy out
there with hangover candles and that's
my boy joey piedmont over there hanging
over
colorado's finest bro yup a good guy he
sent us in some beautiful candles and
joey i like the wide the wine bottle
ones because there's more easy to get
that wick with that lighter
because i've cooked both of my thumbs
look like i'm trying to burn uh
cook crack rocks on my knuckles all
right well 90 sorry
89 of fans also prefer candles